pour débuter la page politique retour
sur la démission de Joel rau il a
confirmé qu'il quittait son fauteuil de
maire de plaisir tout en restant au
conseil municipal il s'expliquera
officiellement sur sa décision après la
notification du préfet en attendant nous
avons recueilli les réactions des
Plaisirois et des
plaisiroises l'annonce n'a pas encore
été officialisé mais la nouvelle se
répand déjà auprès des Plaisirois leur
maire Joël rau a décidé de quit
je comprends pas pourquoi qu'
démissionne c'est dommage c'est un bon
MRE on l'aimait bien c'est toutah il
doit avoir une bonne raison c'est
peut-être parce qu'il en a marre il est
fatigué il veut prendre sa R et puis
c'est tout cherche pas à comprendre
c'est qu' une raison sil veut plus je
sais qu'il avait de santé donc je pense
que c'est lu est j'en sais rien je suis
étonné qu'il n'aille pas jusqu'au bout
de son mandat c'est tout je l'ai appris
en début de semaine par une cliente qui
est allé à une réunion voilà je me pose
des questions est-ce stratégique
est-ce pour des raisons de santé on n
sait rien
entre étonnement et questionnement la
raison de son départ reste flou contacté
par téléphone Joë réot nous a confié
vouloir préparer les prochaines
élections municipales en mars 2014 une
très bonne image on a eu des bons
contacts ensemble on a jamais souci avec
lui non non franchement rien à dire
B pour la petite enfance je trouve qu'il
a pas fait grandchose vraiment une très
bonne image je il a fait une excellente
administration de la ville depuis qu'il
y est et on ne pourra que regretter son
départ moi ça fait qu'un an que que je
suis à mon compte donc j'ai pas vraiment
de rapport avec je ne connais pas
particulièrement mais j'ai pas à me
plaindre en tant qu'habitante de plaisir
Joséphine colmans berger son adjointe à
la culture et à la communication est
pressentie pour reprendre le poste le
maire UMP occupa cette fonction depuis
2001 ne connais pas cette dame mais je
pense que si c'est Monsieur Réau qui a
choisi de lui donner sa succession ça ça
doit être favorable c'est une passation
de pouvoir c'est tout c'est pas il il
passe la main à Madame Colmas berger et
il reste au conseil c'est une élue déjà
depuis son le premier mandat donc c'est
une femme qui est très bien il y aura
aucun problème avec elle
Joël Réau annoncera son départ ce jeudi
soir lors du conseil municipal de
plaisir le maire a préparé un courrier
qu'il adressera aux habitants de sa
ville pour les informer de sa décision
il répondra officiellement aux questions
de la presse dès l'approbation de sa
démission par le préfet début novembre
un conseil municipal extraordinaire
devrait se tenir le 15 novembre